كل هذا لم يبدأ في
السابع من أكتوبر، بل كان مستمرًا منذ عام 1948، وقد أوضح
مؤسسو الدولة الإسرائيلية
تمامًا أنهم سيقومون
بتطهير الفلسطينيين عرقيًا منذ
البداية، وهذا ما
فعلوه منذ عام
1948.  مرة أخرى في 67 فعلنا مرارا
وتكرارا ونحن نفعل ذلك طوال هذا
العام قبل وقت طويل من أكتوبر أه السابع
يعني نتنياهو وقف أمام الأمم المتحدة
في سبتمبر بخريطة مسحت كل
إشارة إلى فلسطين أوضحوا
نتنياهو  قال في وقت سابق من هذا العام لن
تكون هناك دولة فلسطينية
قال سموتريش إنه لن يكون هناك شيء اسمه
الفلسطينيين في مارس
2023، كان هذا العام الأكثر دموية بالنسبة
للفلسطينيين منذ سنوات قبل أن يحدث أي شيء
في السابع من أكتوبر والناس
في منظمات حقوق الإنسان
الشعب الفلسطيني في  لقد
ناشد هذا المجلس الناس في السنوات القليلة الماضية
أن يتحركوا ويضعوا حدًا
لإفلات إسرائيل من العقاب على جرائم الحرب والجرائم
ضد الإنسانية، لقد فشلتم في
التحرك وبصراحة أيديكم ملطخة بالدماء
بسبب ما حدث منذ ذلك الحين
بسبب فشلكم أه في التحرك ضد
إسرائيل